because the number of lawsuits over
climate change has more than doubled
over the last six years as environmental
groups use courts to pressure
governments and companies to act and
there have been some notable successes
in 2019 the dutch supreme court ruled in
favor of climate activists who demanded
action from the government more recently
gas company shell was ordered to cut its
worldwide emissions by 45 in the next
decade but what happens when
environmentalists lose and does it cause
more harm than good
richard to you first of all
how effective is a tool
a tool is litigation uh in tackling
climate change there has been a rise in
lawsuits around the world haven't there
i think
1896 cases have been filed but
do many of them actually make a
difference
i think very few of them actually make a
difference in terms of reducing
emissions i think the two that you
mentioned there are
by far the two standout
cases here they can also make a
difference in other ways of course by
creating publicity creating awareness
shining a light on on what's going on we
we've just had a court a a case for
example in scotland about proposed new
oil development which which lost but
nevertheless has helped escalate the
issue up the agenda i think at other
times though if the badly judged case
can do more harm than good for a number
of reasons one is that if you get a
court ruling against you saying that a
project you're opposing is legal well
then you have it now from the judges
that it is legal so you kind of lost
that one and the developers have
something to fall back on that they
didn't have before at times it can also
be a bit divisive and in the case of mr
bolsonaro i'm not sure anything is
really going to work with him part of
his political persona is that he's
defending uh ordinary brazilians
interests against the outside world that
wants to tell brazil what to do so it's
hard to see that even if he loses this
particular one would have a vast amount
of impact ct what do you think do you
think the fact that action is taken
against an individual against the
company against the government even if
it's not successful it has some benefit
because it raises awareness what's your
take on it
yeah i i i have to agree with richard
again here um i think it is very
important that we use litigation as a
tool to raise awareness um but i don't
think we can just rely on litigation as
a solution because these processes take
a long time to to you know conclude and
they involve a lot of people um but so
they need to be coupled with other tools
um but what i would say is that i think
we need to do a lot more research on how
litigation actually impacts
environmental climate outcomes um that
you know it's it's about how which
litigation measures actually was
effective in reducing a certain amount
of emissions or which ones were not so
we can have a learning
session on how how best to design
litigative measures um in order to
achieve the outcomes that we want
richard very briefly that is a point
takes a long time doesn't it and
everyone keeps saying we've got very
much time to to sort this out we haven't
got much time yeah i think cc made an
extremely good point
yeah i think cc made an extremely good
point there um
court cases do take action on the other
hand when they come out well like the
agenda one in holland you get very quick
action so like cece said i'm going to
agree with her totally
learn the lessons make the call make
smart
pursue smart litigation not on smart
litigation okay richard black cece who
always good to see you both thanks very
much indeed